[Musica]
ciao a tutti
difficile stare sul palco dopo la minima
spinelli po di pressione
allora vi racconto la mia storia ero in
vacanza a riccione nel 2006 in estate
ero in viale ceccarini con dalle mie
amiche e mi improvvisavo pr per una sera
un perché prima vacanza 17 anni pochi
soldi bisogna cercare di entrare gratis
in discoteca
allora vedo due ragazze attraversare la
strada
uno era stupendo e l'altro va bene
normale e dico raga ci penso io vado là
e dico colonnello vuoi venire a ballare
stasera quello meno carino mi prendo il
fire dalle mani e mi disse sì se viene
anche tu e io faccio lascia parlare il
ridge di beautiful
egli ridicolo bello apre che aveva aveva
criniera folta moro mascella pronunciata
vuoi venire a ballare si sera e l'altro
miri dice poi il meno carino
smettila lui è fidanzato in 5 secondi si
era infranto il mio sogno d'amore
quel ragazzo che quel giorno mi in
francia del sogno si chiamava marco
simoncelli
per chi non
per chi non lo conoscesse ci tengo a
precisare ma forse sono un po di parte
che sarebbe diventato uno tra i più
grandi piloti della storia secondo me
sta di fatto che rimaniamo insieme
cinque anni
e forse sarebbe finita lo stesso perché
eravamo giovani comunque la nostra
storia finisce durante un gran premio in
malesia nel 2011
quando lui abbia un incidente in moto
oggi lavoro per la fondazione simoncelli
che porti che porta il suo nome è nata
per la volontà dei suoi genitori a
dicembre 2011
finanziamo un sacco di progetti belli
secondo me quelli che sono più in
simbiosi con noi e che noi sentiamo più
nostri
adesso che stiamo finanziando in italia
cioè vogliamo continuare a farlo perché
i nostri maggiori donatori sono italiane
però prima abbiamo per esempio donato un
microscopio ai semi di pace onlus per
operare i bambini in kenya e l'anno dopo
abbiamo aiutato la croce rossa di rimini
a comprare un autoambulanza pediatrica
cose di questo tipo l'ultimo progetto è
stato il centro diurno che era un
vecchio albergo sulle colline di coriano
che abbiamo ristrutturato e fatto
diventare un centro diurno per ragazzi
disabili che verrà gestito dalla
comunità di monte tauro
all'inizio
le pause non solo per obbligarvi a farmi
l'applauso perché ci mette un secondo
devo pensare all'inizio non mi piaceva
fare questo lavoro
o meglio non ero convinta c'erano delle
cose che mi veniva molto difficile fare
tra cui rapportarmi con le persone che
magari si mettevano a piangere davanti a
me e io dicevo egoisticamente te cosa e
da piangere
quindi all'inizio ho fatto un po fatica
poi abbiamo finanziato un progetto e
repubblica dominicana
abbiamo costruito una casetta
all'interno di un ora di un orfanotrofio
del ph e la cui delegazione italiana si
chiama francesca rava è una fondazione
di milano
questa casa loro fino a quel momento non
aveva non potevano ospitare ragazzi
disabili
noi abbiamo costruito questa casa
insieme a loro e
da quel momento adesso ne ospitano 30
all'anno mi sembra comunque sto lì
cinque giorni
per vedere appunto come procedevano i
lavori eccetera
la mattina della mia partenza sotto
l'alloggio mi ritrovo tra i tre ragazzi
con cui avevo legato di più che mi
lasciano una lettera
mi strappano la promessa di tornare
presto
io gli lascio una parte di me faccio il
volo in aereo tornando a pensare che
cosa voglio fare dalla mia vita se è
vero se rondelle c'erano dei contro in
questo lavoro però il pro di poter
aiutare dei ragazzi la cui sola sfortuna
era quella di essere nati in un paese
povero
noi non abbiamo la presunzione di
cambiare il mondo perché non lo fanno
l'unicef che con un sito figuriamoci se
possiamo farlo noi ma se possiamo far
vivere un pochino meglio far stare un
pochino meglio alcuni ragazzi poi noi
non da soli come fondazione ovviamente
aiutati dai privati che fanno le
donazioni o le aziende perché no
qualcuno di là mi ha detto hai avuto
l'opportunità di scegliere se cambiare
vita tornare alla tua vita di prima o
lasciare un segno
io ho deciso che valeva la pena scendere
a dei compromessi
quindi nessun lavoro è perfetto tanto
anche in un altro in qualsiasi altro
lavoro avrei trovato delle cose che nome
non mi sarebbero piaciute l'importante
tipo che la domenica sera secondo me
andare a letto non pensare che palle
domani e lunedì se sento lavoro ti fa
star bene e non ti fa pensare che non
hai voglia di andare a lavorare in
settimana è il lavoro giusto o meno in
qualsiasi lavoro nessun lavoro è
perfetto poi passano gli anni sono
passati diversi anni da allora e
tutte le cose che all'inizio non mi
piaceva fare che che trovavo difficili
fari tipo andare un gran premio e fare
attività promozionale raccogliere fondi
era un mondo che avevo conosciuto grazie
a lui non nel 2012 è stato faticoso che
al tramonto dover andare in albergo
quando ero abituato a stare nel camper
e a vivere la situazione ad hoc di notte
qui si è scusato quella situazione di
andare gran premi non mi piaceva mentre
adesso ci vado tranquillamente con i
miei amici o i volontari obbligati che
sono sempre i miei amici
davanti a un pubblico non mi piaceva
stare
ecco diciamo che di là sono un po cagato
addosso però adesso sono qui più o meno
volontariamente vuol dire che dei passi
avanti li ho fatti non non bisogna
secondo me spegnere la luce della
propria della propria esistenza di
fronte alle ingiustizie della vita
io sono qui a dimostrazione che la frase
fatta più vecchia del mondo cioè che da
un grande dolore può nascere qualcosa di
bello
alla fine un fondo di verità fare il mio
lavoro può essere controverso lavorare
nella fondazione del tuo ex ragazza che
non c'è più
sì spesso lo è però chi può dire se una
cosa è giusta o sbagliata se ti fa stare
bene conoscere marco nel 2006 mi ha
cambiato la vita e me l'ha stravolta per
certi versi ma nonostante come sia
finita come è finita
lo rifarei un milione di volte perché mi
ha dato tanto quella volta ho fatto la
scelta più contraddittoria di mettermi
con lui quando c'erano delle cose il
fatto che faccia se il pilota viveva
rizzo ne eravamo distanti anche stavolta
scegliere di lavorare di continuare a
lavorare in fondazione che quando potevo
tornare a fare quello che facevo prima
tornare a vivere a bergamo voltare
pagina e non dico dimenticarmi però
diciamo ri allontanarmi da tutto quello
che era lui
anche questa scelta si è rivelata
fondamentale e mi ha fatto trovare la
mia strada
per questo vi dico fate quello che vi fa
stare bene perché alla fine è lì che
troviamo i nostri sensi
[Applauso]
[Musica]